most people unless your parents are
exorbitantly wealthy and have achieved
everything that you wish to achieve I
don't think you should listen to your
parents and so one of my first rules of
life is never listen to someone who's
poorer than you or poorer than you want
to be alright so that's two different
you know caveats there because you might
be younger and it's like okay well yeah
my parents have more money than me but
like are they bored than you want to be
if so then only listen to people who are
wealthier than you want to pay and the
thing is is that they always will side
on the side of being less risky because
when you naysay right it's like kind of
like when you're um if someone's like oh
I don't like your your girlfriend and
and the thing is is that if you date
then fundamentally every single person
that you date except for the one that
you marry is going to be somebody who
you're not going to be with and if
someone says I don't think this person's
good I don't think this person's good
then they will be right literally 99 of
the time except for the one time that
matters right and so the thing is is
most businesses fail 95 of business
they'll fail within five years and so
most times they are correct and so it's
very easy for them to self-reinforce
that they are so smart right and they're
always right and they can tell you I
told you so but the reality is that they
are wrong in the one person of times
that it matters in your life
Nation watch the top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Alex hermosi and my take on his top 10
was a success enjoy
when I think about this what's
interesting is that like the only way
that is guaranteed to knock you to
success is to never take the risk to
begin with right that's the guaranteed
way of not achieving it and I remember
when I was quitting my job that was the
biggest conclusion that I came to was
that I was not happy at my current
earning level and that the only job
because there was one position one job
that made enough money that I wanted
which was being an investment banker so
the best investment bankers can make 10
20 million dollars a year but I knew
what it was required to get there and
the amount of effort time and sacrifice
and I was like the only people who will
pay me that amount of money
um will be making so much more money off
of me and literally draining my life
that I don't think it's because like
usually if you become an investment
banker successful you pretty much donate
20 years of your life in order to do
that
um and you're you're really never going
to see your family and all that kind of
stuff and for me that was not a
trade-off I wanted to make and so I
figured there was no job that was going
to pay me what I wanted to make and
afford me the lifestyle that I wanted
and so
the path that I was on was guaranteed
to not get me to where I wanted to go
and so even though it was micro risky it
was macro
the only way I could do it right and so
that's one of those like one of those
things actually like from garyvee he
says micro speed macro patience right
money loves speed well plus time and so
if we're trying to build wealth we're
trying to build an asset right then we
need to have time one of my other
favorite things that I'll share with you
is um uh you get paid for what you do
you get Returns what you own right and
so anyways back to the back to the
reason why you shouldn't listen to um
other people is that they don't have an
accurate understanding of risk right and
the biggest risk is not doing anything
at all the biggest risk is never dating
not that you're with this person right
and so Warren Buffett said and I like
this he said most people only need to
make four or five really good decisions
in their life so think about that for a
second because I think about like that
one really shook me because I think
about all the decisions that I make
every single day right and all the
decisions that I've made in my life and
there's really not that many of them
that have been the biggest libraries but
the few that have been have been massive
and enormous lovers in my life and most
people don't take enough time to think
about those decisions that are the
massive force in the road am I going to
keep going in this position do I want to
live in the city am I going to marry
this girl who am I going to go to who am
I going to get into business with what
are we going to do right what are we
actually going to do in this business
and so people don't give put enough
thought into that stuff and spend all
their time thinking about whether what
next show they're going to watch on
Netflix right rather than thinking like
I'm going to take some time with this
decision because one of my other sayings
is mistakes love a rushed decision right
so micro speed macro patience if you're
looking at long playing long then you
have to understand or at least this is
my you know my two cents on it is that
most people will oppose you at all times
and that is because it is safer for them
to do so because they will be right most
of the times but on the one percent of
times that they are wrong it's that one
percent decision
saying that you're going to buy Seas
candies for 25 million dollars and ends
up generating a billion dollars right in
Revenue it's that one decision that
they're gonna miss out on and that's the
one decision that matters and so they
are 99 of the time right but they're 100
wrong right and so that's the only
message that I wanted to to Really drive
home is that if you have parents who
make less money than you want to make if
you have friends who make less money
than you want to make I had so many
people who told me that everything I was
doing was stupid I was giving up a
really good consulting job to open a gym
right I took all my savings and sunk
into a business and you know what that
business wasn't the one that set me free
it was four four or five businesses from
there but I learned the skills that one
by one I was able to assemble and
assemble on a belief standpoint of the
world with the character traits to
reinforce them to eventually yield the
success that some people think is you
know cool rule number two study wealth I
started studying wealth after I became
wealthy so like what did you learn about
it afterwards and what do wealthy people
do that you think poor people don't do
they pick higher leverage opportunities
in a sentence so like Port Rich Dad Poor
had like Poor Dad says get a job Poor
Dad says get a higher paying job like
Rich Dad says like and the thing is
there's so many innate beliefs that seem
commonplace like well of course you know
what I mean like well of course you know
and you know you buy some real estate
and you know it'll appreciate over time
of course you invest in some stocks like
yeah of course but like poor dads just
don't say that and so you have to like
learn that I think and I didn't so I'm
grateful in that I didn't have to learn
that because I heard that just was of
course yeah once you have some money
like of course you don't spend your
whole income of course you don't and so
there's a lot of of course you don't
that I think I I inherited just by being
in like a saving father but there's also
some upper middle class people who don't
save anything so like right but I think
my dad did a lot of I think he helped a
lot with like money hygiene I think I've
had a lot of really good money hygiene
from my dad the big the big breakthrough
that I had for me was when I stopped
focusing on and this is going to sound
backwards but when I started my gyms I
was all about building the business
right
and when I built the biggest companies
that I've had and now recently sold and
now we have our portfolio it was about
how do we make the most money
and I know that sounds completely
backwards but the only way that you can
make the most money is to provide an
exceptional valued service and charge a
ton of money for it and because I
optimized around making money I I
started going through for a low Capital
expense businesses because I had lost
everything after that five-year stint
and so I was like never again am I going
to reinvest every dollar from the
business back into the business because
I've lost it before so when I started
the the next business in every business
I've had thereafter like we take
dividends every month and we do that
because you don't wait till there's an
accident 10 years later I mean put all
your money in I'd love to do both yeah
yeah why not both sure right and so that
was they get dividend and get a bigger
course yeah but not just put money in
and wait and get no money back 100 and
the thing is is and this was a fallacy I
had because people always talk about
like reinvesting in their business but I
realized that that just meant that they
weren't making profit and so and so the
vast majority of businesses even the
software world is somewhat shifting in
this
um but they want to see profit and then
even better is if you have net free cash
flow which is just a fancy word for the
amount of money that you can take out
every month after making Necessary
investments in the business and so I
wanted to have businesses that pumped
cash flow because I lost it all before
and so I think there's a lot of like
every every one of my business Seasons I
would say I've had three uh business
Seasons I had my gym ownership period I
had my uh turn around and early gym
launch day period and then I had
prestigious Labs the licensing business
in Allen that was like my last season
were you exited yeah yeah and then I'd
say like now we're in we're in our this
our third season I guess so brick and
mortar gyms licensing supplements and
software and then you know third season
is what we have now and each of those
has a huge huge magnitude of Leverage
that was added to it and so you know
this like gym launch was started on
accident in that I was like this might
be a way that I could make money rule
number three develop good skills you
absolutely just need skills you can have
nothing else in your life and a
beautiful thing is that no government
can take it from you no person can take
your skills from you in a divorce
um those are always your own uh which is
something that I don't know for some
reason feels magical to me and so one of
the things that I've seen as I've kind
of you know moved moved up I'm not
saying that arrogantly just you know it
just developed progressed whatever
um is that the people who I surround
myself with now have more money than the
people that I surround myself off when I
was early on in my career and what's
ironic is that these people actually
spend less money
they they have they have less desire to
spend money
and they find ways to acquire things for
less money out of pocket and um that's
always really interesting to me and so
right now I think there's you know if
you were to if you were to look at quote
investment opportunities right
um you could you could you know invest
in buying a house so let's say let's say
you've got I'll do two scenarios all
right let's say you've got fifty
thousand dollars all right
and you're like okay I'm thinking about
buying uh a house right and I think for
a first house you might only have to put
10 down I'm not sure it's 10 or 20. yeah
I don't remember but anyways let's just
say 10 for for sake of whatever so 500
000 house all right you put 10 down and
then you get the mortgage right you get
the liability of the mortgage payment
every month yippee
um now if you were to if you were to and
let's say that in order for you to save
that you've been making
I don't know 60 Grand a year and you've
been saving that for you know five years
something like that now let's look at an
alternative scenario where you are still
making that same amount of money 60 and
you saved up 50. and instead of buying a
house you have a long conversation with
your spouse and you say or maybe you
don't have a spouse whatever with
yourself and you say
I wonder how much money I could get for
this money
ah interesting right and so you you Leaf
through the businesses that are in your
area and by the way the best way to do
that is one you should contact Brokers
not necessarily to buy a business but to
get an idea of some of the businesses
that are in the area and what price
ranges look like but if you buy from a
broker you're going to pay retail you
could definitely negotiate a deal and
I'll tell you one of the deals that I
did that was really good at the end of
this
um
but uh anyways so let's say you you know
you reach out to some businesses things
that you like or enjoy or feel like you
have some specialized knowledge in
and uh you find out that there's a
business that's doing let's say
I don't know
250 000 a year in uh in in profit right
and uh because it's a small local owned
business and you're not going to pay
retail for it you get it for two and a
half you know times earnings right which
would be
uh which two and a half times uh it's 5
25 hopefully I think two and a half no
that's 625 excuse me 625 000 is what a
business you might pay for businesses
doing 250 000 a year in profit all right
now here's where here's where it's
interesting right so I had
um an early Mentor who taught me this
negotiation tactic that I've used pretty
much for throughout my entire life since
this moment and I used it in the deal
that I'll tell you about in a second
which is a grew on price then agree on
terms right and so when you when you
would go to quote talk to this business
right there's there's the price which
you might say cool you know this
business 625 and then there's terms
right and so the term side once you've
agreed on the price you negotiate down
whatever
and then you say okay well I'm going to
need you to seller finance meaning
you're not going to pay anything you're
going to pay them over time right I need
you to sell or Finance uh you know three
quarters of the deal all right and so
three quarters of the deal man I'm doing
some math today but like 400 and you
know 30-ish 437 whatever thousand
dollars
um
and they're going to finance that for
you know three years right
and then on top of that or five years
you could do whatever you want here I
think um I mean you could probably I
mean you try and push it out as far as
you can right and then what you have
remaining which would be like in this
instance 200 000 then you get a note
from the bank right or SBA loan which
you have a 200 000
um loan for it and you put your your
fifty thousand dollars down right so
then that would be 200 uh so you put 50
which would be 25 of 200 000. so I'm
going to recap this 625 is the cost of
the business you know 437 you get seller
finance meaning you can pay that over
time and then you've got two hundred
thousand dollars that you get a loan
from the bank so uh which you put fifty
thousand dollars for
so if you're thinking about this the guy
who's selling the business he sells for
625 but he's only getting 200 000 up
front you're only putting 50 of that 200
and you're taking a loan for the rest of
it right
um and so when you're looking at this
you've now acquired this business that
makes 250 000 a year right so you
upgraded your income from 60 to 250 000
right and within you know 24 months
all of that you know income will be
yours uh and maybe hopefully you'll grow
it or you'll probably try and work extra
hard and take over some of the some of
the other positions or cut out some of
the waste Etc in the business and uh and
and so that massively speeds you up in
life right and if you compare that to
what it would cost you to start your own
business
um in terms of investment and like
existing book of business client lists
all the knickknacks you have to buy that
you don't even think of zoning permits
and all the fees and licenses it's
actually pretty decent deal
so
um
I'll tell you one of the deals that I
did that was pretty good so I had four
locations at this point this is one of
the gyms and I opened a fifth location
so the first two locations I opened I
opened the first one I think for forty
thousand dollars I mean I put I didn't I
put as little as I possibly could in
this thing
um and it happened to have been at old
gym so there was like Turf already in
the flooring was already in it was
painted like there was a bunch of things
I didn't have to pay for so I lucked out
there
um
and but the second one because I thought
I was smarter I put 200 we put 250 000
into the second location and here's the
fun thing it made no more money than the
first location did uh which I always
think is hilarious so like uh to the
undisciplined everything looks like a
spending opportunity uh it's uh I pretty
much would empty my bank account and uh
and so on my fifth location uh my next
two locations were corporate locations
which are actually pretty cheap
um which was pretty cool those are those
are good deals but the the fifth
location that I did I had a gym that
went out of business or not out of
business he wanted to uproot because his
it got divorced or he had some some
family crisis
and so he's looking for someone to buy
his his gym and so it was beautiful it
had all this equipment that was really
expensive in it and I was like man this
is like a dream come true and so I
agreed on price because I had my mentor
talk me through this I agreed on price
which I think was 40 000. I think it was
40 Grand it was 40 or 50. I think it was
yeah so that's what I agreed and then I
was like cool
I'll pay you over the next year
and he was like fair enough
and so I mean you didn't say it like
that we negotiated and then 12 months is
what we what we came to and so I mean I
tried to go for 24 months uh but he
agreed on 12. and so the beautiful thing
with that was I didn't I didn't put any
money out of pocket so you know my first
year I put 50 Grand in second gym I put
250 000 in fifth gym smarter more
experienced me puts no money in right
and in the first 30 days we did 51 000
in sales
so this gym in the first 30 days
literally paid for itself period right
and so this thing that is now kicking
off profit right every month
during this during this whole period of
time
and then 12 months later I ended up
meeting Russell and telling him how I
was doing this stuff and he's like you
should be teaching other people how to
do what you're doing now and so I ended
up selling the gym for one and a half
times more than I quote bought it for
right which I then had the gym pay for
it on its own and so I basically
acquired a cash flowing asset for
nothing
and then had just acquired a cash
flowing asset for for no money and so I
think about that
um in light of the original thing that I
I mentioned was just like I get I get
people who message me all the time like
what happens if I don't have any money I
don't know what to do you always have to
just get skills or this is just my
opinion is that because there's no one
who can take them from you there's no
divorce there's no government there's no
Revolution there's no financial crisis
that can ever take your skills from you
and that's why when entrepreneurs hit
zero they can usually bounce back I've
done it I had 1100 in my bank account
um at one point at my at my lowest point
after I had six gyms right after this so
even when I had this experience and it
sounds cool like I messed up and um you
know that's why I think I love the
saying you only
should only have to get rich once and um
and that's why people who are wealthy
are more risk-averse because the
downside risk of losing everything is
always bigger right like you can reverse
30 years of great decisions with any
number multiplied by zero any number
multiplied by zero you could have a
billion dollars if you make a bad
investment it goes to zero right
and so that's why when people are like I
don't know why you're motivated and I
don't know why uh they're like it's just
there's there's just always things that
can happen you know what I mean and so
just being risk-averse is what I have
noticed from the people who have the
most money is that they actually have
way lower risk tolerances than the
people who have no money uh which is
hilarious because it's like the people
who have the least amount of money uh
then go buy lottery tickets which are
literally the worst investment you could
possibly make
and and and they they consistently
invest their money in a terrible
investment that has all the downside
risk of going to zero whereas the
richest people in the world find things
that could never go to zero and they buy
them for zero so think about that for a
second people are using their money poor
people use their money
to buy things that have virtually
guaranteed you know risk of going to
zero right with tiny risk of of upside
right whereas rich people buy stuff for
zero dollars that have
um upside potential but that doesn't
that doesn't have a billion dollar
upside potential they would rather have
a guaranteed small return with no risk
than a potential for huge return with
guaranteed risk think about that so um
anywho I think if over time and it's not
like you can shift your perspective on
this overnight it took me a long time
and I still am doing it now
um and shifting how like because I still
get excited about you know I see these
you know these these these
cryptocurrencies 20xing and stuff you
know in like a month and I'm like man
that's crazy
um but then I also think like well the
downside risk of me going to zero is far
more upsetting to me than me getting 20
times more on some tiny investment that
I would make
um and so I I don't do it right
and so anyways
um I say all this to say uh agree on
price agree on terms try and get
something for nothing see if you're
gonna if you're gonna make an investment
in any kind or you're trying to start a
business there's usually a business
that's already for sale or has a
motivated seller an owner who doesn't
want to do it anymore who almost give it
to you for free right and that's the
thing is when you're new you're getting
so excited but you're not patient right
that's why you have to have the
character traits of being successful
before you will see the success because
if you if you have that character trait
you'll look and you'll say I can take
six months because in the in the decade
of my the next decade of my life there's
no rush but me making a good deal or a
bad deal of like should I put all my
investment in this thing or should I be
able to get something that makes four
times more money for free you can do
that you can do that and I'm telling you
I talk to business owners every day I
mean guys making a million two million
four million dollars a year who
literally have told me they're like dude
if someone came today and offered me
like guys who are making a million
dollar a million dollars a year in
profit or like if someone had offered me
200 Grand right now I would take it I'd
system so tired of this business so like
there are opportunities they're just not
listed anywhere you just got to look for
them rule number four manage your
expectations
expectations are literally the thing
that will destroy your life uh or will
make your life and many of us uh I think
many people in general have you know
figured out and many world religions
have figured this out which is uh you
know the secret to happiness is uh
haves over wants uh which is let's say
you have you know have one thing and you
want nothing
you will be infinitely happy the problem
is where you might have a million things
but you want two million things and you
will not be happy right and so you can
simply change how happy you are by
expecting less
and so one of the things that I
specifically wanted to address today was
the expectations around education
and the reason this is a really
meaningful topic for me is that I've I
think I've talked to you about my
neighbor
um and watching him go through the the
crazy expectations that he has as a
young person has been really valuable
for me because I've also seen a lot of
those characteristics that he has in
myself just add zeros to it but it's
still fundamentally the same thing and
that's what's been uh it's been
meaningful for me and so anyways
uh
I have tried to frame things so if you
are trying to learn things which is
going to be the first step to any kind
of entrepreneurial Endeavor is I like to
liken everything to a bridge because I
think it's a simple visual so imagine
where you are on one side of you know
this this Valley right is where you are
and where you want to go is on the other
side of this big valley right and you
have a bridge that goes across the two
sides
now the problem is is that people will
buy
things they will buy courses they will
buy mentorships they'll buy workshops
they'll buy seminars they'll buy events
they'll buy whatever right in an effort
on some level to get over this bridge
right of where they are to where they
want to go and it could be from zero to
a hundred thousand dollars a year it
could be from a million dollars a month
to two million dollars a month it could
be from 100 million dollars a year to a
billion dollars a year whatever it is
there's a bridge right and
along that bridge are bricks and I like
to liken
um each skill as a brick on the way to
where you're trying to go and the
problem with the expectations of
somebody who's trying to learn a skill
or achieve a goal is that they have a
binary outcome I either achieved it or I
did not I either am making a hundred
thousand dollars or I am not and the
problem is it can be incredibly
frustrating because if you have a binary
outcome uh then it's very easy to get a
zero out of one right where the reality
is most things are exist on a Continuum
and so this is the difference between a
psychological binary and a and and the
biological Continuum which is I'll give
you a couple of examples so it's not uh
uh are you diabetic are you not diabetic
it's how diabetic are you right it's not
uh are you smarter are you dumb but it's
how smart are you right and so we like
to psychologically bucket things into
yes no's because it's simpler for us but
it it it misses actual reality right and
this can be especially dangerous as
we're trying to acquire new skills and
so the reason I liken this and I think
it's so dangerous in education because
that's what we're doing right if we're
trying to educate ourselves we're trying
to acquire skills is that we think as
we're trying to get across this bridge
that let's say you buy a course on
copywriting right and so you're on one
side of the bridge you buy a course on
copywriting and then you still aren't a
millionaire wow right
the problem is uh you may have put
another brick on your Bridge you may be
closer
to where you were to getting to the
other side of the bridge you just
haven't achieved it yet and so this is
one of the issues that I also see
um just in general like it's so funny
because in the in the in the I'll say
quote Guru World
um you know people will take on a coach
that coach will move them forward you
know to a certain degree and then
they'll take another coach and that
coach will move them forward to a
certain degree and so forth and so on
and then the thing is is that they're
they're like I'm working with so and so
I used to work with that person they
suck right
but the problem and I used to do this
right like and this is why I think it's
so ridiculous
um is that like if you were looking at
your schooling right and you had a had a
third grade math teacher and then later
you had a calculus teacher you wouldn't
be like screw that third grade you know
uh math teacher the stuff that I'm
learning from this guy is so much you
know more advanced whatever right and
I've had you know a lot of our clients
say that about their franchises that
they work with and things like that and
I just it it drives me nuts because it's
it's stupid you know it's for lack of
it's stupid because a lot of times you
need
you need step one to get to step two
right and you don't have to and P it's
because people have psychological issues
but like they they can't they can't say
I've learned from all of these people
right and it doesn't it doesn't decrease
your status to say I've learned from
many teachers look at all the richest
people in the world they say like I've
had multiple mentors I've had so many
people help me out over the years and I
think if you can shift that perspective
it will be incredibly valuable for you
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five quiet your ego I
think that the whole ego death concept
that we were talking about the very
beginning I try not to talk about this
too much because I think it's it's um a
lot of people find take offense to it
and I don't mean it that way I sure this
is just what worked for me and not as a
criticism of any anyone else's beliefs
for me the idea that there was no such
thing as Legacy that when I died
eventually everything that I had would
become dust
and that anything expanded over a long
enough time Horizon disappears right
which if you are like Christian for
example it's the whole book of
Ecclesiastes
um
if you and I think the realization of
that allowed me to quiet my ego a lot
so that I could be more present in the
idea that like this moment will only be
here in my mind and anything that I do
here will not last and so
it shifted how I worked it shifted how I
saw relationships and a lot of my
thinking is around like my 85 year old
self I feel like my number one Mentor is
like my fictitious 85 year old self
because it's the only person that I
really believe has my best interest at
heart and is no ulterior motive and so
there's this there's this tweet that I
had that went pretty viral but it was
like
listening to a billionaire or a
millionaire I'll just use that like when
I was in my 20s I wanted to be a
millionaire and when I was a millionaire
I wanted to be in my 20s
and so the idea that my future self
would trade all the money he had to be
poured in 20 again made me really
reanalyze how I saw living life in the
moment if I literally in the future will
value my present moment more than the
achievement of the thing that I'm I'm
seeking right now in the present
then something's something's off because
even my future self knows that because
right now I would pay all the money I
have to get 10 years back
it's not even thinking about it and so
then all of what I'm going to achieve in
the next 10 years I would happily give
up to be right where I am right now
and so I think thinking about that
really shifted a lot for me because it
helped me quiet I'm not saying eliminate
but quiet some of the thoughts that are
more ego driven because the ego always
wants to like separate and isolate from
others and prove that it's better and if
I know that it will all be dust there is
no better because we're all going to be
destined so in that same way if like if
we're all going to be Dustin we're all
siblings like two very strong frames for
me at least it helped me quiet that
aspect and I think in that way I was
able I think you can ask my people but
like I think I was able to show up
better as a leader there was better able
to show up better as a husband
um so I better like to make content
things like that like I don't think I
could have made the stuff we make now
five years ago because I still think it
would have been more it would have been
to proving something yes perfect 100 of
improving proving someone proving a
fictitious foe wrong
right right they're all talking about me
right no one cares about you exactly and
so that was really and it's like I had
to shift from like no one cares about
you to
like
I really want to have a shirt that says
no lives matter but I feel like
no one cares about you yeah yeah but I
feel but I think there's like a lot of
like meat to that where it's like if we
can because in that way we are all equal
and so as I think it's almost the most
egalitarian perspective is that like in
the end we will all be dust yeah and so
I think in that way that's like we have
these exchanges that we have
um and in some ways it makes it more
beautiful number six be the best version
of yourself why are you trying to change
people's perception of you when you can
just change who you are and let their
perceptions catch up the only way you're
going to change your reputation is by
being different he's like you need to
stop being this person that does all
these things and your reputation will
catch up and even if it doesn't you'll
always know and honestly it barely
scratched the surface because my ego was
so high and I was like no I just have to
think of a better way to like Market
myself but I ended up knowing that he
was very serious about the threat of
pulling me out of school if I didn't get
my grades up and so what I ended up
doing for the next half of the semester
of my first semester freshman year is I
didn't go out at all I didn't drink
anymore I really didn't like hang out
with girls at all and all I did was
study and I was able to pull my might
have been one two it was very low up to
a 3.2 for the semester which basically
meant I got an A on everything from that
point for the rest of the semester and
so when I went back home he was like
well now you know you can do it and so
we should always expect that that is
what you're gonna get from here on out
and it also kind of proved it to myself
too I was like I guess I can do this and
and you know what happened is after I
started switching that way
people still thought of me as a [ __ ]
and I still had to deal with that it
took like two years to really reverse
the reputation that I had acquired in
the first three months I think during
that period of time I grew an
appreciation for how easy it is
especially in First Impressions to set
the wrong one and how hard it is to
overcome a negative impression and my
reputation overall the realization I had
was there's too many people that you're
interacting with in the world to try and
curate reputation
the only way to change your reputation
is to change who you are reputation is
fundamentally just what people say about
you to your face and behind your back
I'm not saying that you need to care
about what everyone else thinks that's
not really the point of this it's much
more if one person says you're an
[ __ ] whatever if every person you
know says you're Nestle like you might
be an [ __ ] and so if you have one of
those situations where you feel like the
proof or the evidence is overwhelming
and you might even believe it then it's
probably you I think that for me getting
out of the hole like I can control this
and try and curate what people think
about me and transitioning to be like at
the end of the day I'm the only person
who knows who I am and I don't like who
I am and just saying like well how can I
get to a point where I would like me
even if everyone else hated me how can I
like me when I started operating from
that place it really changed my life
because then I started thinking like
what version of me do I want to be and
what does that guy do well that guy
studies really hard and that guy works
out really hard and that guy's a really
good friend he's always respectful
doesn't have an ego and it took me a
long time and I still work on this stuff
you know what I mean I'm not saying I'm
done by any any sorts of imagination but
but I think that if you can simply shift
the perspective of like I'm going to try
and appear this way to like I want to be
this way if it just so happens to get
captured great and if it doesn't great
and there's this this quote by big Titus
that I'm probably gonna butcher but he
says if you need someone else to tell
you something about yourself you are out
of Integrity because you can always be
your own witness I think that that's a
great point to wrap the this little
video Lesson up with because that piece
strikes to the core of everything which
is we are our own Witnesses and if we
want to change our reputation we need to
change a reputation with ourselves first
and then eventually it will reflect in
the world rule number seven use
negativity to grow Envy is having the
the desire
for something that someone else has that
you do not have so you're lacking and
someone else has something that you want
and do not have that is Envy jealousy is
when you have a threat that someone is
going to take something that you have
that they do not have all right and so
for example I'll give you an example of
each so Envy I may be envious of a
friend of mine so um I was actually
talking to a good friend of mine who
owns a big weight loss company and right
now he's doing better than I am and now
I am envious of his success I am I can
feel it I'm envious I got off the phone
I was like I'm envious of you right
on the flip side if someone comes to
talk to Layla right it is the fact that
they pose the threat of taking attention
or her attention that I think should
continuously belong to me that I would
feel jealous over I haven't had I
haven't felt jealousy in a long time but
that is that is an example it could also
be like with your kids if you have some
you know some other adult in their life
starts taking their attention or has
more influence over them you are jealous
of the influence that that person is now
is threatening your influence over your
child right so two examples they're
nuanced but I think it's important and
when I was talking to Nick barely about
this I was talking about how I think
Envy um gets a bad rap and I'm not going
to go into the spiritual religious side
of this or even the happiness side of
this because I think Envy absolutely
does not make you happy
but I do think that Envy will make you
successful all right and so this this is
where I want to kind of dive into this
Envy is adaptive right as human beings
this is actually from our old brain
right this is animals have this too they
are envious of one another and it's
because if in a group one person or one
being one animal whatever brings more to
the table you are now envious of that
person and what it does is it elevates
the rest of the group to go and achieve
the same which is good for the
collective not happier for each of the
individuals but is a pro survival tool
right and so for me understanding this
and at least being able to name the
emotion rather than saying I don't like
this guy or I'm angry at this person or
having this negative feeling that you
cannot put words to instead being able
to say I am envious has been very
relieving for me because now I can
actually tell those people hey I'm
envious of you and for some reason I
think it just creates another level of
Candor because it's a certain level of
vulnerability and saying you have
something that I wish I had but then
you'll notice that the conversation is
not defensive on that person's part most
of the time they're like well let me
help help you and it's only when we guys
our intentions or trying or trying to
feign you know pretend to be a different
way than we are where people also can
sense that you're being disingenuous
like great job man right when you
realize deep down and they can tell from
your your subtle tonality changes and
the way you look that the um that you're
actually not happy for them right and so
I think if you can at least say it then
it actually gives you power now
in terms of judging your motivations
because obviously you might think that
Envy is a bad uh motivation
it is my belief that I would rather deal
with people who do good things for bad
reasons than bad reasons for good things
um or I said the same thing twice but uh
they do the right thing for the wrong
reasons rather than the wrong things for
the right reason all right I'd rather
someone who does the right outcome and
he gave me an example that was really
powerful he said a friend of his was a
top Navy SEAL
and uh you know one of the best Navy
Seals he trains Navy Seals just a total
badass right and before that he was an
EMT
and he talked about his experiences
being an EMT is that most people think
you know EMTs have to be really caring
that you want them to you know they have
to save these people's lives every day
and he said uh the Navy SEAL was saying
I was not compassionate at all I didn't
really care that much about the person
who was on the table in front of me but
what I did care about was my stats I
cared about the status of being the best
I wanted to have the fastest to the
hospital I want to have the highest
survival rates highest success rates of
the people that were under my care
because I cared about myself being the
best and so the question is
if you were the person who was on the
table having a heart attack would you
rather have the compassionate EMT or
would you rather have the
self-interested EMT who is doing it for
status well if it were me I'd rather
have the guy who wanted to Pride himself
on being the best in the world and
didn't even care about me at all because
I knew his result was going to be more
Pro me than the other persons and so I
think that as as humans as entrepreneurs
we judge ourselves a lot on our
motivations and our in our intentions
but I think that if we can take a step
back and a name the emotion so that it's
not this amorphous thing that we can
understand but then take the next step
and say is this is this a pro-adaptive
emotion is this something that's going
to help me or is this an emotion that's
going to drive me to do something that
is negative and I think at least even
even in naming that we can increase the
time between emotion and action and the
further that time Gap is in general
the better the quality of the decisions
we make because the more rational we are
we're never completely rational because
we're we're emotion driven beings and we
have limbic systems that override things
but the more we can decrease the
triggers of the emotional triggers that
that cause us to make bad decisions
ultimately the better decisions we make
and so
I I say all this to say big picture
first naming the emotions is important
second it creates space so we can make
better decisions third we can analyze
those decisions and say is this
something that is going to help me in my
life or is this something that's going
to hurt me and then as a result of this
we don't have to judge ourselves as
strongly on why we are doing things and
rather what is being done uh because
candidly I am a very envious individual
and maybe this is me just
um
rationalizing my own negative you know
emotions who knows
um but at least for me
saying it that way and framing the
thought process in that way has helped
me feel uh better about myself and just
not or really just less bad if that's
probably a better way of saying it and
not constantly berating myself for
having desires that I think are wrong
and so uh Dan Sullivan said this and
I'll end with this is that
when people want something if you want
to make more money if you want to have a
bigger house you want to have a bigger
car you want to build a podcast Studio
whatever right
he said wanting is reason enough
because so many times we ask but why do
we want that
we're probably not going to change the
desire
and so letting us letting ourselves
desire things and giving ourselves
permission to desire things and myself
specifically has been incredibly freeing
and what it's done is given me a
tremendous amount of my attention back
that used to be allocated to analyzing
why I'm feeling this way or why this is
right or why this is wrong and instead
accepting the fact that I want something
and that wanting it is okay as long as
it is not something that is hurting
other people and that it's not something
that is hurting me rule number eight
obvious deserve your behavior how do we
behave the reason that this is so
important is that it's one thing to know
where you're going but it's another
thing to know how you're going to get
there and so this is just as true in
business Partnerships and marriage in
terms of what you want uh to have happen
and how you want to get there
um as it is in business okay and so what
I want to do is actually just walk you
through the three values that we have at
acquisition.com and why we believe them
and so from an overarching perspective
the way to come to values is to look at
what are the non-negotiables okay and so
what I mean by that is and every company
is different because the core thing
about values is that they have to be
things that are true and innate to you
right like for example at Southwest uh
have fun is one of their core values and
if someone does not want to have fun or
does not believe in the processes that
they do to have a good time then that is
a non-negotiable for them that person
cannot work at that company it is a
fireable offense and so these are not
aspirational these are not things you
would like to have these are things that
are core to who you are as a person and
as a team all right and so when you
decide on these non-negotiables they are
by their very nature non-negotiable
which means that you hire based on these
you Fire based on these and these are
the core Spirit of the team and some of
the mistakes that I see when people make
values is that one they don't draw the
line in the sand and so one of the core
things about a value is that it has to
you have to be able to say this is not
this right you have to be able to say
okay between Justice and mercy we lean
towards Justice or we lean towards Mercy
which means you have to repel people
with your values all right and so if
your values do not repel people then
they are not values they are platitudes
okay and so it's very important the next
thing is that when you're making your
values the values themselves need to be
ideally said in words that you would
normally say so if you have little
sayings inside of your community then
then a lot of times those can become
some of the values you have so for
example Jim launch one of our first
portfolio companies uh speed is King do
the boring work these were different
ways I mean we could just say work ethic
but that's not the way we would have
said it we could have said be fast or
fast turnaround times but speed is King
was the way we would have said it okay
and so some of the things that I've
learned with this is also you cannot
have too many values as in I'll say it
differently you can have too many values
you have to be very selective at the the
true core values of the company all
right and so if you're you know between
two a lot of times you just have to
chunk up uh and kind of get a broader
value but they become the core and I
think that what we have found is that
three is The Sweet Spot and that number
is continued to distill down over time
but I think three is the amount that
your human brain can comprehend as
lenses to make a decision right and the
reason these values are so important is
that when you scale the company you have
to scale decision making which means you
have to scale the frame with which you
duplicate the decision-making process
which is should I hire this person even
though Alex is not involved in this do
they align with the core value values
and the more stringent the values the
easier it is to have a black and white
example of I think this person means two
out of the three or one out of three but
we only accept three out of three and I
will tell you this as an additional
point if you have core values in the
business I would relay them to all
aspects of your life if you would not do
business with someone for a decade do
not do business with them for a day it's
one of the navalisms that I like a lot
and so if you wouldn't if you don't want
to deal with this client for a decade
don't deal with them for a day if you
want to deal with this employee for a
decade don't deal with them for a day
you have to and and the extent to which
you hold your line of intolerance around
these truly non-negotiables will dictate
the health of the organization and if
you make these non-negotiables and
realize that there are people in your
organization in your client base that do
not ascribe to these then you must make
the changes to fix it and that is the
pruning of the tree that will ultimately
grow the tree all right these are the
short-term pains for the long-term gains
remember 9. shift your perspective I
think the single greatest differentiator
between the poor and the middle class
middle class and rich rich and the truly
wealthy is how they see time and if you
think about money as simply a condensed
unit of time right that's all money is
like you trade it for time I mean you
can trade time for money so like it is
they're almost equivalent units and the
people who know how to master their time
the most mean that they know how to
master their money the most right and so
really if you want to master to the
original question of like how do wealthy
people come wealthy is because they
Master their time and so time Horizon is
just like the perspective from which we
see what we want to achieve and so if I
am doing if I'm building a company from
the place of like I believe that this
company should exist I believe this
problem is worth solving and that is
where you start it from then you build
it differently versus versus I need to
make money I need to make money this
week I need to make money tomorrow
because what can I go make money with
exactly and so I think like I mean
you've built this amazing brand here
if if people were able to
not ask for 12 months and just serve
animal number 10 the last time before
some very special bonus Clips is take
Act action now when
now
now it's never gonna work forever and so
I've seen this happen in so many
different situations where people will
try and give themselves a reason to not
even begin something because they think
that there is an end to it when the
reality is the only things that don't
actually have an end to them are things
that you do not understand and so if you
don't if you see something as a forever
option
then it probably means you do not
understand it well enough to begin doing
it so there's a little mind for you
um and so let me give you a couple
examples to bring this home so you know
when I was you know in the fitness space
I'd have a lot of people who'd come up
to me and be like hey man like I want to
start working out I want to get bigger I
was like awesome you know this is how
you got to train blah blah and they'd be
like well I don't want to get too big
I'm like
you don't even look like you work out so
why don't we start with that and then we
can worry about you getting too big
right so it's not a perfect example for
business but that's an example of
somebody trying to Discount starting
because they think they cease an end
that they do not even understand the
journey well enough to comprehend
another example would be hey we're
running Tick Tock ads right now and
we're crushing it right and someone says
well
we don't know how long tick tock's going
to be around or SnapChat or insert
whatever new opportunity there is and so
we don't want to do it right
but the reality is all opportunities are
by their very nature Arbitrage where
you're taking advantage of
inefficiencies within two systems or two
markets and so over time all Arbitrage
disappears right and then markets become
more efficient that's how markets work
right more and more people see the
opportunity the bit the Arbitrage
decreases until eventually it's
efficient right
and so when you're looking at
opportunities and you see something and
it might be a big opportunity but it
only is going to be open for two years
three years
do you do it or not it's another series
of questions that would happen after
that but I would not discount it simply
because you know that it is finite
because all opportunities are finite and
to take this exaggerate you know this
example to a Max degree of exaggeration
think about the Fortune 500 there's only
one company that's been on there for
over 100 years and that's GE just one
one company right and so every one of
those companies you might have thought
or during their day would have been like
this thing's gonna be here forever the
reality is it's not and markets change
so rapidly it's difficult to reshift an
entire infrastructure some companies can
do it many fail and so if your business
is founded upon taking advantage of an
Arbitrage opportunity or an efficiency
in a Marketplace or something that is
fleeting right that comes and goes
that's okay many businesses were built
off of Arbitrage opportunities they
created cash flow human resources that
could then be deployed and pivoted in
another Direction when the opportunity
closes and so it's kind of like saying
well I don't want to invest in this
investment because it's only going to
Triple my money in three years well what
do I do after it triples my money will
you take the money you invested
somewhere else right it's the same
concept except you're just applying it
to your business and so this is just a
caveat that was top of mind that I
figured I'd share with you because just
so many times we try and take 10 steps
forward without even realizing that
there's this big pile of money and you
can just pick it up and move about your
life and it doesn't need to be forever
and so it's just remembering like if
this were an investment would you triple
your money in three years probably
so then don't worry about what you're
going to do in 20 years because you're
going to be such a different person then
anyways you might not even want to be in
the same thing forever and so I think
sometimes we just create this reason
because the real reason is that we fear
failing when something seems so easy
right we fear failing because we might
not think we're good enough or we're
being lazy and we don't want to even
start or try and so it's usually the
fear thing but for some people you
shouldn't you get off your ass
um but anyways I hope I hope you found
this valuable uh maybe this you're at a
decision right now where you're thinking
about investing something or you're
thinking about taking advantage of an
opportunity or think about investing
your time into uh taking advantage of
some sort of inefficiency and if it's a
massive one even if it's going to be
fleeting as long as the return is high
enough I think of many times it can be
worth it so um anyways this is more
targeted for newer uh entrepreneurs if
you're in an existing vehicle it means
you've already found an Arbitrage
opportunity so don't try and do another
one unless it's something that feeds
your original model
you need someone who you can trust like
if you're giving someone your money like
or you're trying to take someone's
advice or counsel you need to trust
their intentions all right and so it's
not just whether they have integrity
it's whether they have your best
interest in mind all right so I'm going
to get to how I solve for that in a
second but that is the first character
trait of you need that you need of a
council of somebody of any kind of
counsel really whether it's investment
law Etc
the second
um is efficacy or their skill set right
so let's think of both let's think of
just different scenarios here so let's
say you might trust your mom implicitly
but she doesn't have the skill of
knowing much about you know how to
structure insurance policies or trusts
or you know investments in Tech startups
right you might not have that skill but
you might trust her intention right for
you specifically on the reverse of that
you might see that there's this person
who's got lots of skill is prodigious in
this but it also means that they know
exactly how to screw you if they want to
right which is one of the double-sided
things of being really good at something
right you know all the details you know
how to write the agreement structure the
deals in order to make sure that you you
know get the best outcome right and so
the idea is to find someone who has both
your best interest at heart and has the
ability to deliver on what you want
right and so it's both of these things
and so you're like well yeah maybe that
seems obvious for me just even boiling
it down to that was very helpful for me
because when I look and I look through
advisors look for people I want to get
counselor from I have to look at these
two things all right so here's how I
test for the Integrity piece and here's
how you can kind of like you can control
for risk here right one is I always try
and interview as many advisors as
humanly possible all right and I do that
because I'm going to get as much
information from each of the council
during this process that will give me
perspective from which to make a
judgment right one of the biggest
problems with this like if you think
about Julie who's trying to lose weight
right she goes to the gym and then she
talks this 10 personal trainers one
personal trainer says it's all about
high fat low carb another guy says hey
don't worry about that keto stuff it's
all about high carb low fat and then
another guy says no you really just need
a balanced thing and another guy says
it's only about calories it's only about
counting your Macros and so you get this
huge perspective so that hopefully you
can make a judgment call otherwise when
you talk to the first guy and he says
it's all about keto then you're like
well I guess this is it right I guess
these guys all have opinions when in
reality there is a truth you just don't
have the perspective in which to make a
judgment yet and so the first step in
this is that I interview as many as I
possibly can from reputable sources so
this is where I reach out to my network
I make posts Etc to try and get as many
referrals as I can alright so that's
step one step two for the integrity is
that I try and have a line incentives
now a lot of times there are incentive
systems that appear aligned but not are
not in reality so let me give you an
example so in the real estate market if
you're a realtor for example you may
think oh this realtor has my best
interest at heart right because they
have an incentive to sell the house and
so that is why they're going to get
compensated so they want to sell it for
as much as possible ah that they aren't
incentivized to sell it for as much as
possible they're incentivized to sell it
as fast as possible and get a deal
closed all right and so think about this
for you selling a house for 500 000
that's worth five hundred thousand
dollars is a normal you know that like
that's normal that's the market price
right but for you to make an extra let's
say twenty five thousand or fifty
thousand dollars would be really
material that would be a huge extra
outcome for you you would probably push
a lot harder to get the extra 25 or 50
000 now let's say that um you could
probably sell it in a day at 450 000
because it's below the market value of
the house right now here's what's crazy
is that if a a selling realtor you know
like total it might be seven percent two
percent goes to the buyer and five
percent goes to the seller if five
percent is going to your realtor five
percent of 500 000 right is 25 Grand
okay and so for them the the fifty
thousand dollar decrease to drop you
from 500 to 450 means that they're going
to give up twenty five hundred dollars
so they're gonna make twenty two
thousand five hundred so let me ask you
a question now in the reverse if they
sell for 525 they're going to get 27 500
right and so it's a 5 000 swing off of a
you know 25 000 nut for them and one of
them might take them three months and
one of them might take them a day so
what is their incentive
their incentive is to get the is to make
as much money as possible per unit of
time and so their incentivized to sell
as fast as possible and so this is one
of those things where you have to put
your thinking cap on and say are our
incentives truly aligned and so when
we're looking at this when I say there's
two aspects that I look for Council or
somebody who's going to help me do
something financially legally Insurance
wise whatever it is so first is that
Integrity piece and are there incentives
aligned the incentives being aligned and
you could restructure that deal and say
hey you know what you're going to get
zero percent on anything below four
hundred thousand dollars I'll give you
three percent on anything between 400
and 450 and then from 450 and up I'll
give you 20 right or 15 or whatever
right and so now they're highly
incentivized to push and now your
incentives are aligned because each
increment for you is worth almost as
much it is to them and that is how you
would align incentives all right now how
do you test for the second thing which
is their skill set this one's hard all
right especially if you don't have the
perspective from which to make a
judgment which when I enter new things
when I'm trying to learn about trust and
I'm trying to learn about investment
things and different Vehicles I'm
learning about storage units more about
multi like you're like oh man there's so
much stuff and there's so much Nuance
that you have to have right and so the
first thing is I like to usually read
two to three books on the topic all
right and I read two to three books just
so I don't appear like an idiot
um and so I can at least understand what
they're saying and they're going to
respect you to they will it's kind of
like defense if you bring your if you
bring at least some level of knowledge
they don't feel like they're going to
take advantage of you so this is this is
the first thing that I do and this is
because I don't like feeling exposed in
these types of conversations the second
thing you can do is if you have someone
that you can trust you can bring them in
alongside you and the third thing that
you can do which is probably the the
most and highest recommended is
repeating the same action I said in the
first hand which is try and talk as to
as many of them as possible and then you
will gather the insights and you'll see
the people who demonstrate the most
expertise and what you can do is take
what one person says and say well what
about this and see what they reply with
right and as you gain gain more and more
knowledge and this is how you so in the
Consulting world this is qualitative
research right this is where you're
literally doing interviews essentially
to gather information so that you can
make an informed decision right and so
when you do these interviews and this is
what this is the lazy part this is what
most people don't do is they won't do
this work right they won't take the time
to interview 20 people or 10 people when
in reality these one decisions the guy
who you decide to you know invest in in
their fund or if you decide to buy this
building or invest in a fund that that
buys X Y and Z right or you'd or you
have somebody who who manages your
portfolio whatever it is right that one
decision can be one of the most if not
the biggest influence on your total net
worth over a long period of time and
people take more time to figure out what
they want to where they want to go on
vacation than where they're going to put
their money right and so my ask to you
is that if you if you put these put
these lenses on think about both of
these lenses lens one do I think this
person is Integris do I think this
person has my best interest at heart and
then two do they have the skill to
deliver on that promise because I don't
want my mom doing my my investments I
know she has my best at heart but she
has no idea what she's doing and then I
don't want somebody who absolutely knows
what they're doing and does not have my
best interest at heart right which
honestly unfortunately is a lot more of
the cases that that you'll come up with
and candidly you know a lot of times
they're literally incentivized against
you you know uh in the insurance
industry they're they're kind of
incentivized to rip you off it's it's
it's pretty terrible and there's a lot
of Industries like that mortgage brokers
are incentivized to rip you off and so
you really have to look at it from both
lenses and these types of decisions can
make the biggest impact on your net
worth and your financial future simply
based on who you decide to work with I
would say there are days that I feel
like less energized or things like that
for sure not about like the big picture
of like I don't believe that this cause
is not worthy but I do think a lot of
people have that too where they're like
what I'm doing is meaningless right and
then I get into I think everything's
meaningless and then we can just create
whatever meaning you know we choose to
because if we don't believe in a capital
M meeting which a lot of people disagree
with that's fine but if you don't
believe in a capital N meaning I think
that's very freeing because then you can
create Little M meaning for whatever you
want and so if you believe you can then
choose to architect your own life in
whatever ways that you deem meaningful
and make the activities you do aligned
with that meeting the difference between
capital M meaning and Little M meaning
and this is kind of like the basis of
nihilism which people have like a very
negative Viewpoint around which I'm not
entirely sure about why but like
capitalized meeting means that like this
is the meaning of life period like for
everyone this is the meaning of life
whereas if we say that there is no
single agreed upon meaning of life and
then people say well then that is your
big meaning of life and I'm like yes
you're right I believe that there is no
meaning that is the meaning that I that
I believe and they're like well then
that is the capital then sure that's my
capital A meaning is that there is no
meaning
what's the implication of that it means
now that we have meaning making machines
in our brain and so we get to create and
Destroy meaning as we see fat and so if
we choose an activity and we deem that
goal meaningful because we think it's
more interesting or it energizes us then
we can ascribe meaning to that and do
more of it and what's nice about not
having capital M meaning is that that
can shift right that might be good for a
season and then it can shift I will say
that the downside of not having capital
M meaning which I consider to be
religion off the shelf is that it's more
difficult because you have no one who's
saying here's the big box of rules you
can read it and then that way you don't
have to make the decisions about it but
I think it's more difficult but and
ultimately more rewarding if you have
reasoning behind why you believe what
you believe because then you have to
independently come up with your own
conclusions about those things it also
makes it malleable so that if you get
new data or new evidence then you can
change your mind which a lot of people
again have difficulty with but like if
you change the information then it would
make sense that if it materially changes
the outcome that the way that you
believe about something should change
and I think a lot of people will
identify with their beliefs as a part of
themselves rather than as what I prefer
to call them which is assumptions
because they work the same way what's
the difference in belief and assumption
not a lot right the only difference is
just what we call the word and so
assumptions are based on things that
we've observed and then we assume
something as a result and so I would say
that beliefs are just assumptions and
but when you call them that they become
less tied to your identity if you have
an assumption you don't say you
challenged my assumption it's like well
yeah it challenged my assumption Ah
that's great I I was assuming this it
must be this and then they become much
more flexible and then we don't tie our
egos into them and I think ultimately it
serves more people better in the long
run a lot of people I would say
mistakenly think that the number one
resource is time
right everyone's like time is money time
is money time is money
and I would argue that that's not
necessarily true I would argue that
attention is mine that is the golden
resource so the billionaire friend that
I have he's actually uh been helping me
on um the new Endeavor that we are
launching to our gym alerts uh soon
which I think will change the industry
anyways he's been helping me with that
stuff but like here's an example on his
phone his phone does not ring unless you
are already a contact that has been
whitelisted his phone doesn't ring it's
he's impossible to reach the more
successful the more the the larger your
company grows the more you scale the
more you need to scale and really to
scale you is because you don't have a
finite amount of attention and so what
happens is you have to decrease all of
the other things in your life that drain
attention because you can have as much
time as you want but if you're not there
you're not potent you're not able then
you can't get anything done with that
time that you're supposedly allocating
which is why a lot of people end up in
this in between state of always
everywhere and at the same time nowhere
right and so they're they're everywhere
but they're not paying attention to
anything and that's and the reason that
it's difficult to focus is because
entrepreneurs the character trait that
made us into entrepreneurs is that we're
go-getters we're we're risk averse we're
creators we're innovators we're Builders
right we have all of those traits but
the difficulty is is that the thing that
gets you from zero to one is not the
thing that gets you from one to two
right and so one of the the reason that
you have to totally morph and why you
have to be growth oriented individual is
because you have to change your own
individual character traits in order to
progress as a business owner and so like
I said the things that got you here are
not the things that are going to get you
there the things that got you here which
is your own internal skills are not the
things that you need to pass on to other
people so the only way that you are able
to grow your business at a certain point
is by growing other people right and the
only way you can do that is if you have
the attention and the bandwidth in order
to do so and that's why if you look at a
business owner and like the more I
obsess on looking at billionaires and
people who are doing better than we are
is I look at how quiet and how clean
they keep their space and I mean that
both in a literal sense that like their
surroundings their office their house
their homes their cell phone their
computers right there it's it's it's
quiet right everything like it's it's
pristine and when you talk to these
people there's a certain amount of of
Tranquility that's there and
and they just they just have very low
tolerance and it's not that they're
trying to be impatient with you or I'm
patient with the world it's just that
they understand that they have so like
they're they're operating at such a high
level that there's so many things that
are demanding of their time and
attention that they just like they can't
and so they have to forcibly remove
themselves from so many different
situations and I'm going to give you an
example so one of the people that I'm
I'm I'm somewhat mentoring right they
had they had four businesses and this is
something that happens so many times it
lit like like you want you want a
hundred thousand dollar coaching this is
what happens in hundred thousand dollar
coaching sessions and I'm being honest
with you what happens is someone who's
coming in usually doing between one and
three million dollars a year
um can't get past a certain point right
and the reason they can't get past is
because they only have so much attention
and if it's spread between four or five
different kids that's when the gym owner
has four gyms and is making less money
than they did when they had one gym
because the amount of attention that
they can allocate to one facility has
gone down so much that with fixed costs
they basically you're breaking even
right and so the same thing happens now
that entrepreneur is probably making one
to three million in gross revenue but
not taking anything home because they
don't have the attention to actually put
onto things and so in order to grow you
need to do less
in order to grow you need to do less and
that comes from both delegation and also
choosing what not to do the better you
get the better the opportunities that
you have to say no to imagine the level
of opportunities that we have now I'm
just being honest so imagine how many
things we could do or try and JV with or
do a partnership with or whatever
because of the distribution Network that
we have and the trust and the Goodwill
that we have with the gym owners
um that we have in our Network right a
lot I get you know how many people cold
message me like I have an opportunity
for you I'm like really you have an
opportunity for me and so the better you
get the better your opportunities you
have to say no to which is why becoming
a higher and higher and higher level
entrepreneur is more and more difficult
because it requires discipline
it's not about doing more it's about
doing less because we innately want to
do more so doing more of your own
internal characteristic if that was what
it took to get to be more successful
then everyone would be more successful
because it would be something that does
not take effort because that is
something that we already do it's like
man I outwork anyone I've got all this
work ethic cool that gets you from zero
to one
it's not going to get you any further
than that so stop identifying with that
it was something that I used to identify
with I was like I'll I'll outwork anyone
or whatever like that was something that
I used to think about and it was a
character trade it was an identity thing
and the more you grow the more you
realize that your identity needs to be
fluid because what it needs to be is
exactly what it needs to be at that
given time of development because the
character traits that I'm going to have
to emphasize in a year are going to be
different than the ones that I have to
emphasize now the skills that you need
to learn like delegation leadership
those are things that are not the things
that take you in the beginning you have
to be independent you have to be
hustling you have to be grinding you
have to be willing to put in the work
because no one else will do it for you
especially if you have no Capital to
start which most people who are on here
are in that situation to reel this back
in the number one thing that you have to
be paying attention to is where you are
paying your attention
right like you spend attention that's
why they call it paying attention it's
because it is a resource and most people
don't pay attention to that right and so
one of the things that a lot of people
don't know about I mean this one's going
to go along
um what a lot of some of the things that
a lot of people don't know about me is
that I for nine months paid a coach to
teach me one thing which was to manage
my attention
was to teach me how to think and so for
90 minutes every single day all I did
was talk about what I was thinking about
think about that
every day I paid attention to where my
attention was
and when I did that all of a sudden my
business blew up right and I realized
that I had toxic relationships I had
toxic relationships with parents I had
toxic relationships with friends or
pseudo friends things that I that were
taking my attention past things that I
had on my mind that I knew I had not
handled so those are called like open
Loops or open Cycles right so when you
have something that you like I haven't
resolved this and you need to handle
that and you'll get that attention back
because what happens is you have this
bowl this tiny little bowl of marbles
that each of those marbles is is a unit
of attention right if you had to measure
it and so you put little marbles of
attention on your childhood traumas you
put little marbles of attention on your
marriage you put little uh marbles of
attention on your health you put little
marbles of attention on your
spirituality and then massive marbles of
attention on your business but the thing
is is that sometimes you need to quiet
and collect all of these other little
marbles so that you have more potency
more potential energy more potential
units of attention to spend on the one
thing that you're trying to grow which
in this case would be your business and
what's interesting is that what happens
is that things that were perceived as
difficult become really easy and I don't
know if you've ever had this happen but
like if you were in college or you were
in high school and you're like man I
can't solve this problem this math
problem and you were exhausted then you
go to bed then you wake up the next
morning and then all of a sudden it
seems really easy or you're like I don't
know why I didn't see that before
because attention gives you the ability
to see
right like if you're if you think about
wisdom right wisdom is an ability to see
what other people cannot see right two
people are presenting the same situation
the wiser person sees things that the
other person does it and how can you see
better you see better if you have more
ability to see which comes from your
most valuable resource attention how
much horsepower do you have and so look
at the things that you have in your in
your life right now like if I see
someone who has a messy relationship
life who's got a messy love life who
goes out every weekend and gets trashed
right like I can tell you billionaires
don't do that that like the whole Tony
Stark like vision of the entrepreneur is
a farce it's not true don't believe that
every single billionaire every single
high-level entrepreneur is quiet
unbelievably quiet they keep themselves
completely isolated they have a bubble
around them of of layers of protection
they're like like for me it's it's me
and then there's Layla and then we have
our CEO and then we have our executive
assistant team because we have a team of
EAS at this point we have four
um who work the next level there's no
one who has direct access to me
including our employees no one does and
that's because it's it would disserve
you you guys our gym owners if everyone
had access to me the reason that I don't
respond to Facebook messages is not
because I don't want to it's because I
literally can't and if I did I would be
disturbing everyone because then my
attention would be split because someone
can't generate leads in them or whatever
you know what I mean like because these
little things these little things that
are perceived as huge issues to you in
that moment because you have a little
bit of attention you you have so little
left that everything seems like an
explosion but when you have lots of
capacity City big problem seems small
and small problems seem big and it
sounds reverse because what you do is
you start seeing that all of these
things are attention drains and you just
say I don't want to play anymore
and you stop playing we think that for
some reason we are doing something wrong
when we are not self-caring because it
is bad too not self-care because we
should we must or else or what and the
reason this pisses me off the reason
that I made a tweet that went viral this
morning about this is that weekends are
new for humans they're not even 100
years old 1929 in England is when the
first weekend got passed by a union and
it's because people hated what they were
doing for their life and so if you want
to truly give self-care then stop hating
what you do every day novel concept I
know stop hanging out with people that
suck mind-blowing like I said I know and
the reason that I am so passionate about
this is that I have been told throughout
my entire life that I was working too
much I was not balancing the things that
I was supposed to be balancing and you
know what who gives it's my life I don't
need to live by anyone else's rules and
neither do you right and so when people
say you should be doing this you are not
doing XYZ just take a pause and be like
are these rules that I want to listen to
are those your rules that you're trying
to apply to my life because there are no
rules you can do whatever the hell you
want if you want to work for a year
straight work for a year straight and
the reason you can work for a year
straight is because you like what you do
the reason these people try and project
their own self-hatred for their own
lives onto you is because they cannot
imagine a world in which someone might
actually like what they do every day and
didn't don't need an escape a break from
what their existence is on a daily basis
and so don't feel guilty for just being
you and if you don't like your life
every day rather than try and figure out
and make time for self-care it would
probably be better to flip the ratio and
start thinking what can I do in my
actual life to stop hating it so much
that I need an escape from it right and
that's different from like yes you need
to sleep yes you need to you know rest
Etc but there's a difference between
that and like I just need a total spa
day and if that's how you relax cool but
the thing is is projecting on someone
else how they should must need to have
to relax or do whatever it's nonsensical
it doesn't exist right I wanted to make
this video even though it's short
because I it just drives me bananas if
you want to work work if you want to
take off take off just don't listen to
what anyone else says about what you
should do for your life you're going to
die and so will they and it's not going
to matter and in 10 Generations don't
even remember your name so do what you
want you're going to die and that is the
ultimate freedom and for some reason we
live under these chains that we think
exists but don't and so I think the
process of of growing and really making
ourselves free is just simply
identifying the things that don't really
exist and only existed in our mind to
begin with and I think that's why
self-creator really bugs the [ __ ] out of
me or this whole self-care movement it's
also softest like just work right to get
it done you need to like give yourself a
bubble bath every day because like your
work's so hard like humans been here a
very long time we've dealt with much
much harder your you know boss having a
deadline the next day is not the worst
that you've been through and so as a
final sign off on this think about the
hardest things that you have been
through in your life everyone has gone
through hardship everyone has had
difficulties in childhood everyone has
had difficulties with siblings with
parents blah blah blah these events that
shape Our Lives you have been through
harder than this you will survive it
will be okay you don't need to self-care
you don't need to listen to what anyone
else is saying you do you and if that
means self-care by all means but just
don't protect anyone else when I started
in this business I took every single
sale and it was because I was so afraid
that somebody would waste the
opportunity so if you have that fear I
understand where you're coming from
second when I had my first sale that was
not me I I just had this emotional
breakdown because I was like oh my God
this could actually happen and I promise
you if you haven't had it happen yet you
will when it does because you realize
that this business can actually work
without you and other people can make it
rain too right and then I'll tell you a
quick story that illustrate the next
point then would make so as I you know
hired some sales people now that first
sales person were they exceptional no
but they were able to get the job done
later on I had my first kind of like
killer
um and his name was Mario negretti and
he uh he came in
I don't know a year or two into the
business a year into the business and he
so quickly was able to assume the sales
role and to show you how laughable this
is he started and I was about to start
training him and some lady walked in the
door and I was like hey man like I can
take he's like no I'm good he's like go
do your thing he's like Fitness
Nutrition accountability okay I'll
figure it out and he ended up closing
this first lady who walked in the door
for paid in full and I remember walking
in like completely dumbstruck I was like
he didn't even know what the pitch was
but she walked out giggling happy so
excited to start and would that moment
taught me was that
it is good to train sales people but
it's better to take great sales people
and then just point them in a direction
and so this has informed a lot of the
thinking that I have Around Talent in
general and I'll tell you a couple of
Frameworks that have informed this but
like if you look at Harvard Harvard
doesn't produce the smartest people they
select the smartest people and then they
put smart uh professors in front of them
but like the base level of intelligence
of everyone who's at Harvard is already
exceptionally high and so like even if
the teachers at Harvard were not
exceptional the students are and they
would be successful independent of that
because their selection is so ridiculous
right and so if we can think about our
own companies that way and especially if
you're in the service business like look
at the biggest service companies out
there like look at McKinsey look at Bain
look at BCG look at basically a lot of
the finance world is or service-based
businesses a lot of times right and
they're able to do that because they
create such a pool to select from that
they are able to skim for the best
talent right I heard this uh quote from
Esther Kathy who's the founder of
Chick-fil-A you win the championship in
the draft and so it was such a belief
that they had about picking the right
people even more so than training and I
would say that I have moved in that
direction of a little bit more nature
than nurture when it comes to roles
specifically sales especially there are
certain characteristics about building
Rapport about having certain you know
Dynamics or energy whatever you want to
say that like Mario negretti when he
walked in he had all of these things and
he didn't even know the pitch but he won
that sale off of Just Pure Rapport and
so if I'm going to allocate the same
level of time to training somebody I
might as well start with somebody who
has a much higher base because I could
spend 10 hours to take someone from a
two to a four and a half or I could
spend the same 10 hours taking someone
from a six to a nine and the thing is
I'm also going to get more bang for my
buck in terms of my hours of training
with somebody who has natched a natural
Liberty for selling compared to somebody
who does not what's interesting about
this and this is just like my
observation is that you just have to be
willing to talk to more people in the
recruiting process I will say like from
a recruiting standpoint there's there's
two kind of things to look out for if
you're if you're if you cannot pay super
handsomely based on your price points
which you need to maybe fix later but
like if you can't pay super well for the
sales person then you need to look
harder and you'll need to interview more
people and you'll need to probably run
ads and use your network if you can pay
well the best sales people are already
employed and so it comes down to
recruiting those sales people from other
sales jobs ideally from companies just
like yours so that they already know a
lot of the things coming into it so it
decreases the ramp up time for them
because all we were really doing is
swapping products and the actual sales
cycle the type of sale is at a
transactional sales and a long sales and
a software sales is it a coaching
program set whatever it is right there's
so few variables that were changing that
they can immediately Jump and Go which
also allows you to make adjustment on
their proficient you faster and so as a
quick side note to this because this is
something that I've given a lot of
thought if you look at the top sales
people and sales trainers and this is
going to drive Point Drive home the
point that I was making earlier about it
being much of it being born all right is
that if you look at the top people who
are in the space you look at Jordan
Belfort right you look at Bradley you
look at and some people would would say
me in term from a selling perspective
all the guys that I know who have taught
sales were exceptional sales people day
one Bradley started selling cars when he
was 18 years old was the top salesman at
18 years old when he started and he was
like I just found something I was really
good at Jordan Belfort talks about how
he didn't know how to train anybody in
his book and then all of a sudden he for
the first time ever wrote out a
framework to explain the straight line
sale system which became his book and
all that kind of stuff but he up to that
point it was just what he naturally did
right and I can tell you in my instance
as well I'd already closed thousands of
deals before I even consumed my first
sales training and so like I I do think
that if we are selecting sales people I
think it's much more about selection
than it is about training the training
is to remind them how good they are not
necessarily to make them good all right
and this is something that has shifted
over time for me specifically now if
you're like well I suck at sales you can
absolutely put way more time into
yourself than a business would recently
put into an employee all right like you
have you all the time so you can train
you in all your off hours and you're
spending your own time to invest in
yourself but from a return on investment
perspective it's the cost of finding a
good salesperson compared to the cost of
training a bad or mediocre sales person
is significantly lower it's much easier
to find the right people than it is to
take somebody and then make such a crazy
extensive training unless your entire
model is we just take on every single
person who walks in the door like 24
Hour Fitness has this model they take on
anybody who has a pulse and then they
put them through a ridiculous culling
process and then 10 of people make it in
the first 90 days I've said this quote
many times in our communities and on
this channel which is you must outwork
your self-doubt right if you feel like
you're not confident then you must
outwork the things that you're insecure
about if you're like man I'm selling
these services and I'm not sure I'm not
sure if I'm that good at them then do
more of them and don't pretend
honesty is one of the most compelling
and convicting things for persuading
people right saying what you are good at
and what you are not good at truthfully
will we knew far more followers and fans
and and loyal customers and loyal
employees than pretending because at the
end of the day they can feel that you
are disingenuous because they know that
is hollow they know that on the inside
you do not believe the words that are
coming out of your mouth and that is how
people speak without conviction and they
cannot sway others because they have not
swayed themselves because they have lost
their own respect and so I am not the
believer in buying the Ferrari when you
can't afford it I am not the believer in
in affording the home and paying for the
home that you cannot afford because you
want to pretend like this is the
lifestyle that you want to be around if
you go into the guise of networking you
can still go to those places without
buying a four million dollar house when
you you're barely making you know a few
hundred thousand dollars it doesn't make
sense I like Jay-Z's quote around this
which is if you can't buy something
twice don't buy it once I really like
that and so
this is one of the most common questions
I get for newer entrepreneurs because
they think that they have to they have
to they have to pose on Instagram in
order to get to to get wealthy and what
it does is it conflates sequence Jeff
Bezos is famous because of what he did
not because he became famous as Jeff
Bezos and then used his following to
build something Elon Musk is famous for
what he's accomplished not for being
Elon Musk and then creating something as
a result right let the actions be the
thing that gives you the fame rather
than yourself right at least that is
that is Alex's two cents in my viewpoint
in the world and I think most of Mosey
Nation you guys uh share that belief
with me and for those of you who are new
to this channel
um you're going to get more of this type
of stuff uh and none of the Fig until
you make it nonsense that is a sure way
uh to be broke and I will tell you this
as a last thing
the amount of people who in 2008 when
everything crashed who were faking it
until they quote made it
just faked it until they lost it all
because they lost what little amount
that they had because they were so
overextended but I can tell you that
just about everyone can become wealthy
if you choose to live on Lower unless
than you make right and that is a ratio
wealth is a ratio not a number all right
and so anywho if you are having
struggles with this question I would
pause it I would I would beg of you that
you build your own respect first that
you're honest with yourself first and if
you always maintain the Integrity of hey
last year we we got smashed right this
year we'll do a little bit better and
two years from now when you do even
better than that you can be truthful and
people will believe you but if you
always are telling a story about how
you're always doing so well hey everyone
will hate you B no one cares and C you
will know that you are full of it and at
the end of the day I think that is the
only thing that we're going to keep with
us and when we die everyone's going to
forget about us anyways so you might as
well at least enjoy yourself while
you're alive
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome pretend
more amazing rules and Simon sign like
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there and if you truly
aren't failing as you're trying to
innovate then you're probably not
pushing very hard because you haven't
broken anything you're making very very
safe choices we could never put a person
on the moon without a bunch of rockets
blowing up first I met a CFO once I
asked him the priorities at the company
and he said efficiency and innovation